Let's gain some experience in solving equations,
which include simple and decimate fractions.
This equation includes ordinary fractions.
Let's see.
We have minus 1/3 is equal to j / 4 minus 10/3.
I recommend that you pause the video
and see if you can find j.
What value of j will make this equation true?
All right.
Now let's do it together.
I want to isolate the variable,
which I'm trying to find,
from one side.
Since it is already on the right,
to try to get everything that includes j,
on the right side and then
to get rid of everything else
on the right side.
I want to remove this minus 10/3
and the best way I can think of it,
is to add 10/3.
But I can not do this just on one side
of the equation.
Then it will no longer be equal.
If this is equal to that to
be true the equality I do with this country,
I also have to do it with the other.
I have to add 10/3
to both sides
of the equation.
And what will I get?
On the left side
I will have minus 1/3 plus 10/3,
which is
9/3.
And then it will be equal to ...
On the right side
minus 10/3 and plus 10/3
are destroyed by getting zero,
and I only leave with j / 4.
Equals to j / 4.
Now you may think that it is 9/3
the same thing as nine, divided into three.
It will be just 3.
This simplifies things a little.
Three, let me just write it again,
so you do not go wrong.
Three equals j / 4.
To find j,
I can simply multiply both sides by four.
Because if I divide something into four
and then multiply by four, will
stayed with this thing only.
If you started with j and divided into four,
and then multiply
four,
I will have
only j on the right side.
But I can not just multiply
right side four.
I have to do the same
and on the left side.
So I multiply the left side
also four.
And what was left to me?
Four in three is twelve.
Then j, divided into four, four,
will be only j.
We have obtained that j equals 12.
The nice thing about the equations
is that you can check if it really is
you received the correct answer.
You can replace here with 12 for j
and check that minus 1/3
is equal to 12/4 minus 10/3.
Is that so?
12/4 is the same as three
and if I want to write it as a third,
will be the same as 9/3.
A 9/3 minus 10/3 is really
minus 1/3.
Correct answer.
Let's figure out another example.
I have n / 5 plus 0.6 equals 2.
Let us isolate this article,
which includes "n" on the left side.
Let's also get rid of this 0.6.
We will take 0.6 on the left side.
But I can not do it just to the left.
I have to do it on both sides,
if I want equality to continue to be true.
Drop 0.6.
Now on the left side
I will only stay n / 5,
but on the right side
2 minus 0.6, which will be 1.4.
And if you do not want to do it
in mind, you can calculate it
separately.
We will have 2.0 minus 0.6.
You can say, "Oh, that's 20 tenths minus six tenths,"
which will be 14 tenths, which is what it is there.
Or if you want to do it a little
in a more traditional way,
you will say, "Oh, I try to pull out
six out of zero, let me regroup. "
That will be 10.
I will take the position of the units.
If I take one of the position of the units,
this will be equal to 10 tenths.
10 tenth minus 6 tenths is 4 tenths.
And then we carry one from below.
One minus zero is just one.
So it's 1.4.
Now find "n".
On the left side we have "n",
divided by five.
If I want to have only "n" here,
I can just multiply by five.
If I multiply by five,
five by "n" divided by five
will be only "n".
But I can not only multiply the left side
five.
I must also multiply the right side
What will this give us?
We will get n = 1.4 by 5.
1.4 by 5.
Maybe you will decide it in mind,
this is one and two-fifths.
And all this thing will be equal to seven,
but I will do it this way too.
Five in four is 20.
We regroup the couple.
One in five is five, plus two in seven.
And then I will look at all the numbers,
I multiply, I have one figure
to the right of the decimal point.
So my answer will have one figure
This is 7.0 or only 7.
n equals 7.
And you can check it out,
because seven, divided by five,
will be equal to 1.4 plus 0.6,
equal to two.
Let's figure out another example.
That's too fun.
All right.
0.5 of the total
(r + 2,75) is equal to 3.
There are many ways
to deal with this task.
Many times when you see
something like that, maybe
you will be tempted to say, "I will uncover the braces".
But it makes it a little more complicated,
for 0.5 by 2, 75.
You can calculate it and
you will get a true answer if
you do it right.
But the simplest way is
to divide both sides to 0.5.
So I will include more
whole numbers.
If I divide ...
Do not forget that what I do from
the left side, I have to do
and on the right side.
I figured that because
if it divides to 0.5 left side,
I will be able to get rid of this.
And if it divides to the right-hand side
I will still get an integer.
Three divided by 0.5 is six.
This is the same thing as three,
divided by one second.
How many times does 1/2 fit in three?
Six times.
So there will be six.
These are getting shorter.
And then it will be six.
We have now simplified the whole thing
to r plus 2.75 will be equal to,
is equal to six.
To isolate only r from
the left side, I can pull out
2.75 on the left.
But as we have seen many times,
I can not do it
only to the left.
I have - my brain is not working properly -
2.75.
I can not just do it on the left.
I have to do it also on the right.
2.75.
This is simplified
to r equals ...
How much is six minus 2.75?
If you want to do it in mind,
six minus two will be four,
and then if you remove 0.75
will remain 3.25.
If you lack confidence
to do it in mind, you can simply
to write it.
6.00 minus 2.75,
Be careful by arranging decimal places.
Now I have to make some regrouping.
I have zero hundredths
and I'm trying to get five hundredths.
This is not the case.
I'll try to get out of here,
but I have nothing here either.
I'll get out of here.
One unit.
I'll take one of these units.
I'll stay with five units.
And this will be equal to ...
Here I have five units,
and this unit I took,
will be ten tenths.
Then I can take it
one of these tenths.
And I will stay with nine-tenths.
And this will be ten hundredths.
Now I can get out.
Ten hundredth minus five hundredths
is five hundredths.
Nine-tenth is minus seven-tenths
two tenths.
My decimal point will be there.
Five minus two is three.
3.25.
You can check it.
3.25 plus 2.75 is six, 0.5 is really
equal to three.
Again we received
correct answer.